- [Narrator] This video
is taken near the eye
of a category four hurricane
in the middle of the Atlantic
with waves as high as
a four-story building
and winds reaching 94 miles an hour.
The National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration
is sending three state-of-the-art drones
each with its own important mission
straight into the center
of these monster storms.
(wind blowing)
- The drones are a new piece of technology
that is helping us uncover
information about the storms
that we didn't know before.
- [Narrator] Let's take
a look inside NOAA's lab
to see how the agency uses
drones to dive, sail and fly
into parts of a hurricane
where humans could never go.
At the laboratory, a
team of NOAA engineers
work on this torpedo-shaped
drone called the Glider.
It's five feet long, can
weigh up to 150 pounds,
and it's controlled by drone
pilots like Ulises Rivero.
- A Glider could cost anywhere
from 175,000 to $200,000
depending on what sensors
they're equipped with.
- Those sensors are used to track storms
half a mile beneath the ocean surface
measuring water
temperatures along the way.
- Ooh, beautiful.
- Better.
- This is not a handle.
This is where you have
the conductivity depth
and temperature sensor in here,
and this is a dissolved oxygen.
- [Narrator] The unit can find
the warmest sections of water,
which can intensify hurricanes.
- Normally, we dive 'em to 900 meters
and it takes about four hours
so it's about six dives per day.
- [Narrator] The drones
collect data underwater
and send it to computers like this
using satellite radio waves.
- So, one of the things we want to know is
when the Glider goes into the water,
if you look here, this is the actual track
of what the Glider did,
and you see this is like
almost a perfect V-shape,
which is what we strive for.
- [Narrator] When the drones
surface after each dive,
they transmit their location
to Ulises' computer,
which shows up as those
little dots between the lines.
- So here is a map of where
our Gliders are right now.
So, we have Gliders south of Puerto Rico,
these three Gliders right here,
one south of the Dominican Republic,
and one north of Puerto Rico.
- [Narrator] While Gliders
take measurements underwater,
sail drones track what's
happening on the ocean surface.
- They want to get the sail drone
to be at the same location as the Glider.
This way you have information
from the surface down
and then also, you know,
atmospheric information,
'cause the sail drones have
the capability of doing that.
- [Narrator] Built for extreme condition,
the robots are 23 feet
long with a 15-foot wing
that powers the drone,
and solar panels that power the sensors.
These sensors test
surface level temperature,
wave height, wind speed, and salinity
or how fresh the water is.
- And if they are fresh,
we know that they will
remain in the surface.
- [Narrator] And if
that water is also warm,
it indicates a site that
could intensify a hurricane.
So, one of Gustavo Goni's teams
marks those areas on a
map to keep an eye on.
And when a hurricane is coming,
the robots can sail
straight into the storm.
- But still under those conditions
it has to conduct the
observations and transmit them.
- [Narrator] 2022 was the first year
that NOAA deployed Gliders and sail drones
to the same areas of the Atlantic.
And this season, NOAA is adding
super tough, new aerial drones
that can fly through the
200 mile per hour winds
around the eye of a hurricane.
- These drones provide us that information
from the temperature,
the relative humidity,
the pressure information, wind,
wind speed, and wind direction.
All of those factors are key
on how we understand how
the hurricane is evolving.
That data goes into the computer models
so that we can better forecast
what's gonna happen
the next day and so on.
- [Narrator] Shirely Murillo is in charge
of the hurricane research
department at the lab.
For years, hurricane hunter planes
have flown above hurricanes
to take measurements.
- Oh, there goes the signs.
- [Narrator] Today, aerial drones
are launched from those planes
flying into the eye of the storm,
giving experts a wealth of new data
about how these monster storms intensify.
- Hurricane intensity
is a tough nut to crack.
There are so many different
pieces of the puzzle
that need to be solved
from looking at the different
layers of the atmosphere,
from vertically to horizontally
to different timescales
- [Narrator] From the air,
scientists at these
stations pilot the drones
gliding them like hawks
into gale force winds.
Sometimes closer than 100
feet from the ocean surface.
Last year, NOAA flew this
drone, the Altius 600,
into the eye of a category four hurricane
for over two hours,
but the drone crashed
and wasn't recovered.
- We experiment with aerial drones
to see which one is gonna
give us the best information
at the best time while
we're flying in the storm.
And so, you know, it's a trial and error.
- [Narrator] For the 2023 season,
NOAA is also using Black
Swift S0 and Dragoon drones
with a new probe that can
measure vertical winds
allowing researchers to predict
how long a storm will last
at its highest intensity.
As NOAA scientists
continue to chart the seas
in anticipation of hurricanes,
they see the information
provided by drones as vital.
- These datasets, whether
it's in the ocean,
under the water, or even in the air,
they're a key piece for us to understand
and forecast those storms.